Black Friday people it's coming whether
you like it or not it basically has
become our biggest national holiday of
course Black Friday is the day after
Thanksgiving when the retailer is the
big box stores and I guess some of the
little guys we have any little companies
left any mom-and-pop operations it's
when they mark down their prices they
let you know four weeks in advance so
you can get all your weapons ready to
hurt perfect strangers and trample
through people and knock down doors and
step on old people and break necks so
that you can save 50 dollars on Dell
desktop but it is coming and actually
it's not even just the day after
Thanksgiving anymore it's actually
starting on Thanksgiving many of the
retailers will be open including Best
Buy with these crazy deals you get $100
off the iPad and burn under $200 50 inch
LED TV and a you do and it really look I
am I believe in capitalism basically I
believe in democracy and freedom and
everyone should be allowed to do what
they do but sometimes things go
completely insane and I think Black
Friday is an example of something that's
gone completely insane in this country
yes we all want deals and we all want
more [ __ ] everyone wants a bigger TV and
a better laptop and all of that stuff
but the way that people literally wait
in life they're women there are two
women at a Best Buy in California right
now I swear to god that have been
waiting outside for about two weeks
already that means they'll have waited
outside for three weeks whatever they
save on that television how did they not
lose that much do they work I mean just
everything about it brings out the worst
in when people attack capitalism and
consumerism it's all the worst of that
to just plow through people and without
the spirit of the holidays or the season
or anything just to get deals and on top
of that that these stores now open on
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving which to me is
the is actually our best holiday because
everyone in the country should celebrate
it as something that we all come
together about as Americans who give
thanks right we can all give thanks for
something I think and that there now
even open on Thanksgiving not just the
Friday after so these poor people then
have to work often at shitty jobs that
they don't want to do at Walmart and
wherever else it is and so we're making
these people work just so we can get
shittier crap and just save a little bit
of money and it's not what this is
supposed to all be about yet we are free
so I'm not telling anyone not
I'm jus gonna try not to go there and I
guess maybe I'll have to spend a little
more this holiday season but I will
survive